hey everybody I'm John Luke psyche
here's what to expect Pokemon go the
main crux of the game is to get out of
your house and explore walking around
and finding Pokemon to catch there will
be Pokemon in a variety of places but
they tend to be tied to specific
locations so if you're looking to catch
a Pokemon like a Magikarp should
probably head to your nearest source of
water you don't fight the Pokemon you
simply swipe a ball to catch them there
is a little bit of skill involved and
you even get some bonus xp if you do
something like a curve bro
you can of course evolve your Pokemon
using something called evolution shards
which you get by collecting multiple the
same kind of Pokemon like in the
original games items are just as
important and you get these by visiting
key landmarks in your local area going
to these locations allows you to collect
pokeballs potions and even eggs the egg
mechanic is incredibly clever because it
actually functions exact same way it
does in the games every egg has a
certain distance tied to it and you have
to walk that distance before the egg
hatches some landmarks are also home to
gyms which can be controlled by one of
three teams if you own the gym it's your
goal to beef up your Pokemon to make
your gym stronger if you're a member of
one of the other two teams your goals to
work together with other players to take
down a gym so you can claim it as your
own the back-and-forth struggle is
designed to encourage you to get out and
keep exploring checking out places and
controlling territories only the first
generation of Pokemon will be available
in the game at launch but the team is
looking into adding more later let us
know if you're excited for Pokemon go
and for more updates on the game stay
tuned to gamespot
you